nous voulons adopter une charte de la
laïcité dans votre cas vous voulez la
déchirer vous avez dit aux québécois que
vous il fallait vous pensez sur le cas
pour adopter cette charte de la laïcité
alors moi je crois que vous devriez dire
ce soir aux québécois si vous voulez une
charte de la laïcité
si vous voulez vous voulez qu'on
respecte vos valeurs si vous voulez
qu'un gouvernement se tient debout
votez pas pour moi mais votez pour le
parti québécois
c'est ce que vous devriez dire aux
électeurs ce soir monsieur couillard
maintenant ma voix vous devriez tranche
avec les lecteurs et leur dire la vérité
pour une fois vous devriez dire vous
devriez dire au québec tension que ce
défaut que nous ne voulons pas agir dans
ce domaine
vous savez très bien que vous auriez pu
si vous aviez voulu véritablement faire
preuve de leadership et agir en chef
d'état vous auriez pu légiférer serait
adopté rapidement sur des enjeux qui
nous sont communs et sur lesquels nous
entendons vous et moi y compris par
exemple qu'il faut encadrer les demandes
d'accommodement qu'il ne faut pas que
les visages soient voilées ou les femmes
cachées dans des grands vêtements dans
les services publics au québec
il faut que notre patrimoine québécois
sont protégées y compris le patrimoine
religieux ce sont des points d élément
sur lequel nous nous entendons tous vous
avez choisi plutôt par pur électoralisme
échange je vous le reproche mama world
personnellement vous avez choisi par pur
électoralisme d'aller sur un sujet
excessivement délicat et en faire vous
une question électorale
alors je vais vous poser moins de
questions un maroilles vous femme
première ministre du québec aujourd'hui
convient de femmes dans nos hôpitaux
dans nos écoles
mano solo de gamme voulez-vous faire
congédier intéresse sachez qu'il ya moi
il ya une seule femme que j'ai vu perdre
son emploi au québec ou perdre sa
fonction c'est fatima houda-pepin que
vous ne répondrez vous l'avez vous ne
répondez pas
nous n'avons pas l'intention de mettre
affiche de choix
il ya des phases de transition la
défense qui sont prévues oued et les
gens s'adaptent à la nouvelle avec joie
que vous allez déchiré le projet de
chats que nous avons jamais osé alors
les québécois savent à quoi s'en tenir
ce choix voilà le point de vue de ne
sais pas ce que je vais devenir
oui je le serai pour tous les québécois
de toutes les origines qui adhérent à
l'identité québécoise avec fierté et
nous pensons humilié par un gouvernement
qui les met à la porte parce que je vous
le dis si vous d'abord monsieur khouya
vous ne répondez pas à la question de
même que vous n'avez pas répondu à celle
de monsieur les gosses ou le référendum
quand on passe j'ai pensé à vous
dans les hôpitaux la marque à la pomme